my goodness yes even if you're not a
football fan or
you're not just waiting for the outcome
of the game on sunday there's a lot of
time between now and then to get outside
and enjoy this beautiful weather it has
been so
unfebruary-like and that continues so
for your friday right through the
weekend and even into valentine's day on
monday lots of 50s around the valley
this morning we've seen a few 40s now
sunrise mountain 49 45 seven hills a
little cool out at red rock the number
keeps dropping off but they're in the
40s out at red rock and it's a little
breezy out there a little north breeze a
little over 10 miles an hour so i might
want to dress in layers if you're going
out and do a bike ride or an early
morning hike 20s up in caliani and ely
indian springs cool at 36. some 50's in
boulder city low 40's in mesquite 64 and
breezy to windy along the colorado river
valley laughlin and bullhead city both
with wind gusts over 25 miles an hour at
times if you're headed up to southwest
utah for maybe going up to zion national
park or bryce canyon beautiful weather
through the weekend all right putting on
the grill let's get it cooking get those
dogs and those burgers on super sunny
through the weekend let's hear it sizzle
sizzle
yeah yeah get it
we've got 70s all through the weekend
even valentine's day a few sweet clouds
will be sneaking in for
entertaining your sweetheart on monday
but 75 you still can't beat it and
that's kind of when changes will start
especially monday night with winds so
this high pressure will be moved out to
sea and cooler changes will be dropping
into the west by tuesday in the meantime
heat advisories are still in place for
southern california north of l.a all the
way down past san diego until 6 pm on
sunday with 80s for super bowl kickoff
at sofi stadium man it's warm bad
feeling a lot of people are spending
time at the beach there this weekend 58
for our mountains up at kyle canyon look
for north breezes could get up to 25
miles an hour and it's going to be kind
of bumpy winds out at the lake too with
highs in the upper 70s so 77 for us
today the warmest day of the week we
knew today would kind of be the peak and
then low 70s for the weekend 75 monday
here are the changes by tuesday a slight
chance of showers gusty north winds and
temperatures that will drop back to more
february like 60s
next week so enjoy the 70s while they're
here